what's up reject nation greg and john
here today thank you so much for
clicking on this video we are going to
watch from ahead of spoil and by the way
really quick we got our train of busan
movie reaction coming out this week keep
a lookout for that but we're going to
watch them have a spoiler squid game
theories that massively change the way
how you view the ending we'll see about
that paul paul
paul from heavy spoilers changed my mind
paul on the new home alone kid on paul
i'm gonna set a trap and make a cheeky
joke
like a dad joke while i'm at it
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and this is me before
watching squid game this is me after and
that's because the series is filled with
lots of over-the-top deaths challenges
and a major twist ending that has a lot
going on with it yeah because of the
major reveals there's several fan
theories floating around about the show
including how gian almost became a god
his relationship with ilnam the vips and
a lot more throughout this video
but i'm putting a red light on right now
if you don't want any spoilers if you
enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and also make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns your way to
heavy spoilers without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
squid game theories okay so throughout
the series we learned a lot about the
setup of the squid game including the
gods and also those in control guards
became a guard
the vast organization too it could be
that they were selected much in the same
way that all of the players were in
episode 1 we come across a mysterious
character played by gong yoo who offers
gihon two choices he can either pick a
blue card or a red card and gie young
goes with the ladder which could end up
cementing which type of player that he
is
that he could have ended up becoming a
god instead of the player that he was if
we're going deeper into this then it's
definitely a possibility and the gods
themselves seem just as trapped as the
players are they sleep in cells or
killed for even revealing their faces
and though they seem like they're in
control we can see from the way that
they're treated that they actually have
very little power that is a sound theory
i love that because yeah they don't
answer where the guards come from and
they do seem like they're either
employees they don't seem like they're
as equally held captive yeah they're
still grunts and they're still subject
to the will of the vips above them and
even though they get certain sometimes
very nasty privileges it does seem like
they are somewhat victims of the overall
system still they even had like one of
the guards who lifted off their masks
one of the earlier ones the first one
who got killed was a kid if you were to
be thrusted into this position yeah
maybe it must be some type of malicious
recruitment tactic as well whoa that's
actually that's that's a pretty solid
theory yeah and then what are they
playing for working towards or just get
a paycheck health benefits
get healthcare
they also have very little knowledge of
what's actually going on and don't know
who each other are everyone is kept in
the dark so that they can leave the
facility without really knowing the
truth and therefore it seems that this
might be a one-time thing for them just
like the players similar to the players
they're also given numbers and this is
definitely an interesting theory the
more we learn about the game the more it
seems like the gods are almost just as
powerless as the players hinting towards
this perhaps being the case now in our
last video we talked about all the clues
and hints that ilnam was actually the
one in control of the game this included
things like the files starting at two
instead of one him instructing the front
man to end the riots and also the
marbles area being modeled on his
childhood home the marbles one was where
he faked his own death and this enabled
him to leave the game before the numbers
were whittled down even further though
it seemed like the perfect plan it may
have been a last minute one and it could
be that he was actually never supposed
to play in the first place now shout
outs for him zaman who on our last video
theorizer illna didn't actually want to
be picked for this but kiyon showed him
some compassion and this is why he let
him win and proceed to the next round if
we look at the day before
ilnam was incredibly ill or at least he
said he was throughout the games he was
pretty much seen as just a liability and
as the lead-up to the marbles involved
partnering up with people it could be
that he actually intended to come across
so bad that no one would ever choose him
however guillen did and instead two on
two was the one that was left behind i
don't personally buy into that theory
because they constructed the whole setup
the stage for the marvel's game is
played to resemble his home his
childhood home right so it seems like it
was custom made for his desires granted
it did appear based off the flashback of
the ending episode that he kind of last
minute joined the game yeah totally
where frontman was like what are you
doing so maybe it could have just been
that he wanted it modeled after that to
watch the game play out because he's
also buying into the whole thing of
illinois being compassionate feeling
like oh you know keown's been pretty
nice to me i
like i don't know compassion seems to be
really lost in the e3 when it comes to
squid game even for
our lovable old man because as much as
you love him and are near to him those
final moments of him are much more
telling than anything else i don't think
compassion is like you know this goes
actually kind of nice to me yeah
compassion that you would show a horse
yeah a racehorse i've been thinking
about this since faheem wrote it and i
think that the competition from this
point onwards could have gone one of two
ways the first is that illness knew that
not being picked in this meant he'd get
a free pass to the next round because of
this he could purposely pretend to be
ill in the hopes that no one would
choose him and he'd sail right through
it he doesn't make any effort to even
try and get a partner and it's clear
that he just wanted to sit at the back
and keep a low profile the second option
is that he could have used his
opportunity to fake his own death when
212 is left behind at the beginning of
the game the show leads us to believe
that she's gonna be killed because she's
the odd one out however she is saved but
i do think it's possible that had
illness behind at this point that he
would have used it to make his exit i
mean that is a good point because it is
kind of weird reasoning for why they
kept her alive anything else you're like
all right you're you're you're done yeah
yeah yeah excommunicated bye with that
one they're like uh let's justify this
why we keep you alive yeah it does lend
some weight to it actually i think
that's actually a pretty fair theory
yeah and i'm very still yeah you know
there's still a novelty to having it be
modeled after his childhood home and
even if he's not playing the game i
would imagine because he's still you
know spectating the glass hopping game
is super unpredictable because not only
do you have to make sure that no one
gets last place before you do but you
also have to hope that no one ends up
pushing you through one like what we see
the guards at this point were under a
strict policy to kill every player that
attacked another one but they seem to
completely wave it at this point because
it's all part of the game now it could
also be that illness was no longer
playing and therefore they didn't need
to have it in place for his safety but
either way this is one of the most
dangerous games to be a part of anyway
the relationship between gian and ilnam
is sort of a weird one though it seems
like the squid game is some willy wonkas
way to choose someone to take his
fortune there may be other layers to it
and it is possible that ilnam is
actually geon's father now the first
thing towards this is pretty surface
level but nevertheless it's something
that we need to talk about all right
let's see let's do this
are the first and last players of the
game and therefore their numbers have
been clearly put in place to highlight
to us that they are opposites this can
be applied to a number of things
including gi yun being a poor player
whilst ilnam is the overseer of the
entire operation now this doesn't really
bring anything to confirm that they are
related but the numbers are purposely
picked to show us that there is
something tying the two together episode
three gives us the first real big clue
as in that we find that guillermo is
lactose intolerant he can't have the
regular milk that the gods hand out and
therefore he requests chocolate instead
ilnam overhears this and says to him
that he must have been beaten by his dad
when he was younger because he used to
do the same to his son on a second
viewing of the season this line stands
out a lot and there's another one when
the pair play marbles the whole area is
purposely meant to resemble oh it says
me too
that this doesn't really mean anything
comments by the characters definitely
hold some significance now not only does
eel nam find an area that looks exactly
like his home but gi yun also says that
the alley next to it is similar to where
he grew up it is possible that the pair
are indeed related but that they became
as strange throughout their life whilst
ilan was off playing battle royale if
that's indeed the case then the entire
games could have been set up to test
whether his son is worthy to take over
the mantle or not the ending of the
series has him inheriting illness
and joining him beside his deathbed
though it seems like the game dies with
him we learn in the final few scenes
that it's actually still going and
guillen ends up abandoning his trip to
la to stop things from moving forward
okay
yeah i don't want to just fall for every
theory or hear it yeah
you've already said a lot of great
arguments for why that would be the case
i need to re-watch the season again to
see if that thread would really light up
i start questioning some things that we
don't know everything about illness
clearly a wealthy dude why would he not
take care of his son at all or the mom
you know what i always thought was that
it was more figurative
yeah was an actual kind of like my son
or you could have been my son but not
that you actually are yeah because we
kept saying that when watching the show
like you get this like father-son
dynamic or it seems like there's
something kind of happening there in
place and that's why he hunts oh and
dear to him well when he's told his name
you would think that unless he they were
separated when gihon was just so young
you probably remember his death
especially because they have that bit
about like is that even your real name
and he's like yes it is my real name and
you would think the revelation would
come out in that moment too since he's
like divulging everything yeah exactly
and it's his fight he knows it's his
final moments i think there's a lot to
debunk this there's also not so much
that it's like concrete yeah it's like
it could be an interesting thing to
theorize there are a couple questions
that i can't quite get past and then it
makes me think of gihon's uh like
traumatic flashback and he's thinking
about the situation uh the strike i
almost feel like that would maybe work
as some kind of like means of dividing
them up and maybe he's experiencing the
flashback in adult form when it really
happened to him as a child but that's
just me getting convoluted so was
ill-nom did this theory with the mean
illness was rich when he was writ when
he was part of kihan's life and then he
left
and then went off with his rich business
clients and then formed
these games and decided to be like one
day my son will come here and see if
he's worthy enough of inherited this
even though i did not join this by
playing it
i created this but i will test my son's
worthiness by having him compete in it
it's a little far-fetched yeah i mean
inside of that or he lost his family
then made the wealth and was just like
ah forget the family i'm bored i'm just
going to play these games
and guillen ends up abandoning his trip
to l.a to stop things from moving
forward but what if he doesn't and
instead he eventually ends up taking
over everything after all giyon is now
extremely rich and he may end up facing
the boredom that ilnam and the other
vips do we also see the idea of
abandoning a child reflected in his
stance at the end of the scene
ian was supposed to be traveling to a
late to meet his daughter but he's left
there to get involved with the games
instead this could be the writers
certainly hinting to us that something
similar happened to ilnam perhaps hito
was supposed to go and get his child but
instead he took a different path and
ended up abandoning him in order to set
up the games which would be reflected by
geyun who's now doing the same thing
and the next one isn't
our nurses and audience and how we are
very similar to the vips on our last
video overwatch left a comment
discussing how they operate and in many
ways we are very much the same as them
in the season they arrive lounge around
as an audience and watch the players die
for their own entertainment though we're
meant to look down on them and see them
as evil this is also something that we
are doing too as much as the show was a
shock to the system we very much enjoyed
it just as much as they do and similar
to them we're anonymous to each other we
are very much the eyes of the vips sat
in our own homes seeing the games play
out before our very eyes we are
okay let's just clear something up
there's a major difference between being
a billionaire using real-life people
some battle royale certainly you are a
depraved sicko for enjoying this
entertainment audience ever be fully
aware this is a piece of fiction yeah
like if this was a real life story i
heard about i would be like that's
horrible nevertheless show me stop this
and then end this sent the military
right
whoever you need to get in there to stop
this from happening again do it now the
final theory centers around the front
man who we learn is controlling the game
he's the cops brother
figure it out oh very little about the
character beyond the fact that he swung
jen hoe's brother and that he
disappeared in 2015. episode 5 ends with
huang jong-ho coming across a filing
system that contains all of the player
profiles in these he finds his brother
and therefore we can guess that he too
was part of the process because he's
still alive he likely won it and it is
possible that he ended up becoming an
overseer in the system much like our
theory for gehun's future now why i
brought this up is because it clearly
shows that there is precedent for
winning players to end up taking part in
an authority role and therefore it could
be easy for ge young to follow in his
footsteps i think it would be even
wilder if it actually turned out like
young huang jong-ho and the front man
were all in some way related to illness
and that they'd been put through their
paces by their father to see if they
were worthy enough to inherit the game
what i'll say about how i took the
ending because i think you're on to
something and this is kind of a thought
i had too it seems like though because
when he when he got on the phone wasn't
that the front man who was like don't do
this just go home let's just go see your
daughter get on the plane
it sounded like it was the front man who
was talking to him saying like 456 go
it's not like they were welcoming him
to come back come to inherit your form
yeah come in here see if you would like
to take over so what if like for season
two instead of just another round of
squid game action what if there is some
type of trial he has to go there's some
trial they put people through to become
the front man what if he's not the first
person to get out and then come back but
why would he want to be the front man
like why would he i don't think he would
want to be the front man he wants to
expose you got all this money in the
world well yeah and a vendetta against
this entire operation like it would have
to be the greatest not only offer but
like
rearranging of the truth yeah and
everything else surrounding the game for
him to plausibly take it over in any way
yeah cause i mean he even says that when
he's going off he's like i'm going to
tear the whole thing down basically
anyway there's a lot of thing about and
what i love about squid game is that
there's so many different things you can
pull from it make sure you drop your
best theories in the comments section
below and we might end up talking about
them in an upcoming video on the series
i still want to do a season 2 video but
i'm just waiting for more info to drop
but yeah either way definitely keep an
eye out for that thank you paul that was
great yeah damn i really loved the first
half of this too that was the that was
really big it was very incredible it
turns his first couple yeah yeah
absolutely it's crazy to think like this
one show this the creator of this has
created his own little star wars
universe hasn't he yeah and now whatever
follows it up is going to be like so
heavily hyped and scrutinized and i mean
these even answer all the questions
nothing a mystery
just spoiled fun yeah yeah here's all
your theories addressed here's some very
basic answers to who everyone is well
guys thank you so much for being here
keep a lookout for our train of song
reaction thanks paul for allowing us to
cover your video keep killing it looking
forward to more squid game videos from
you yeah don't do anything else
cut it with the batman crap even if
there's no season two just keep doing it
keep doing squid games there's more to
unpack more to unpack fan fiction season
two
see you guys